alors que doit-on comprendre de ce
revirement de position de l'armée pour
en parler rémi landry lee professeur
associé à l'université de sherbrooke et
du lieutenant-colonel à la retraite
monsieur landry bonsoir bonsoir d'abord
vous avez été longtemps dans l'armée le
général lawson dit que c'était un
document qui était pas contraignant mais
quand même quand on reçoit un document
du chef des forces armées qui dit les
autorités actuelles chargé du système
d'enquêté de justice en cas d'inconduite
sexuelle demeureront les mêmes il ya
quand même quelque chose l'a
définitivement c'est que ça dit m
l'étendue de l'anc est fictive c'est
tout simplement c'est que les enquêteurs
vont devoir partir avec ce constat alors
qu'ils seraient probablement plus
favorable le dire bombe a fait une
enquête saint avoir aucune contrainte et
puis par la suite on verra
éventuellement si vous résultats peuvent
être ajustées à l'intérieur des
structures séduit un certain manque
certaines réticences un manque de
volonté de la
peut-être un manque peut-être un déni
encore une fois de
l'étendue du problème ça pour être sûr
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'on était
en mode réactif alors qu'on devrait être
un mode proactif c'est un peu ce que je
reproche au rapport pourquoi avoir
attendu le rapport de l'ancien juge sur
des champs
avant de commencer l'étude j'avais
l'impression que l'année dernière
lorsqu'on a décidé de lancer une enquête
indépendante qu'on avait déjà assez de
preuves déjà assez de faits pour
réaliser qu'on avait un problème mais je
me serais attendu qu'on aurait commencé
immédiatement à faire l'étude donc
aujourd'hui on serait peut-être que
l'invention n'a pas été en mesure même
de faire des propositions au juge les
gens lorsqu elle a présenté son rapport
préliminaire en février je crois au chef
d'état major alors que là on est en mode
réactif et puis ça donne du goût amer
aux gens donc est-ce qu'on est conscient
de la situation à ce qu'on veut de luxe
les formes d'abus nice est une forme de
déni oui c'est ça du moins c'est
l'impression que ça nous donne lorsqu'on
regarde sur un peu de l'extérieur comme
je suis actuellement alors que selon mon
avait dû être beaucoup plus proactifs
dans ce tout juste deschamps a été très
clair dans le corps elle part d'une
culture hostile à g et elle disait très
clairement ça prend un mur aux
indépendants pour recevoir les plaintes
parce que les parce que les victimes ont
trop peur effectivement effectivement
non choisie moi je suis tout trajet par
l'étendue de la situation lorsque j'ai
quitté un la fin début des années 2000
j'étais sur l'impression qu'on avait mis
en place des mécanismes adéquats et puis
là je dois avouer tout simplement que
pour toutes sortes de raisons que la
chaîne de commandement failli à son rôle
premier qui est le bien-être de tout son
personnel cet aspect là fait partie de
la carrosserie 13,7 du chef de s'occuper
du bien-être de son nom et puis là
présentement on ne la preuve que joue
moins pour cet aspect là pour une classe
de gens à l'intérieur des forces armées
canadiennes qu'on a manqué le bateau est
encore là on hésite en vendée il
d'accord on hésite parce qu'on est dans
un mode réactif et puis c'est
l'impression que ça donne aux gens
lorsque vous êtes en mode réactif c'est
un petit peu je veux dire que ça donne
l'impression qu'on cherche à répondre
aux questions alors qu'on devrait être
dans un mode proactif alors que ce une
partie de ses études elle aurait dû déjà
et puis comment je me dis mais on fait
quoi actuellement avec les victimes qui
sont encore ont peut-être sous l'effet
de d'harcèlement ou êtes on fait quoi
avec on va attendre je souffre
simplement et qui sont obligés parfois
acteur je me serais attendu qu'on met
sur pied immédiatement un centre
d'appels pour que ces gens l'option - je
veux dire avoir un certain réconfort et
confort mais pas nous là dessus et quand
le ministre kennedy aujourd'hui oui il
va y avoir ce centre indépendant on va
suivre les recommandations
qu'est ce que ça nous dit qu'ils
ramènent qu'ils rappellent à ce que les
agences ont peut-être pour ramener à
l'ordre mais définitivement dire énorme
et bon ben là aussi sittler arrêtons
arrêtons de parler de supposées quoi que
ce soit d'être un accord en principe il
va y avoir des changements et puis on
voit on va s'assurer il va falloir parce
que finalement je veux dire comme je
vous dis c'est qu'on est en train
d'attaquer l'intégrité de la chaîne de
commandement
c'est ça que les gens ne perçoivent
peut-être pas mais moi comme ancien
militaire comme ancien membre de cette
chaîne de commandement doit c'est ça que
je perçois on a payé notre rôle donc il
faut éventuellement tout faire pour
reprendre cette crédibilité auprès de
tous nous
c'est moi qui vous remercie
m